THIS IS MY IMPROVISED ARMOR.
NOW, IT'S MADE OF
A HIGH-STRENGTH GYPSUM CEMENT
CALLED FGR 95,
WHICH IS FILLED
WITH POLYPROPYLENE FIBER,
AND WE'VE ALSO INSERTED TWO
LAYERS OF COMMON BATHROOM TILES
A LITTLE BIT BACK
FROM THE FRONT.
Narrator: WITH ITS
GEL VITAL ORGANS AS BACKSTOP,
THE MANNEQUIN WILL TAKE THE HIT
IF THE TILE PROVES PERMEABLE.
WELL, HERE AT
THE MYTHBUSTERS ARMORY,
JAMIE SAID HE WANTED TO
TEST THE JAMIE TILE.
WE WANTED TO GIVE IT
A GOOD SOLID TEST.
WE CHOSE WIDE BANDWIDTH OF YOUR
BASIC ARMAMENTS AND AMMUNITION.
SO LET ME GIVE YOU
A TOUR OF TODAY'S ARSENAL,
STARTING OFF WITH A HANDGUN,
9-MILLIMETER.
MOVING ON TO THE HANDGUN,
.45 CALIBER.
THEN TO THE SHOTGUN, BOTH WITH
BUCKSHOT AND THE DEER SLUG,
FINALLY FINISHING OFF WITH
THE HIGH-SPEED RIFLE ROUND,
THE .223.
THAT OUGHT TO GIVE THIS THING
A RUN FOR ITS MONEY.
GOING HOT!
Narrator:
AND SUITED, LOCKED, AND LOADED
FOR THE FIRST BIG TEST,
LET'S PAUSE
FOR A PREDICTION FROM JAMIE.
AS FAR AS PISTOLS GO, THE
9-MILLIMETER HAS A REPUTATION
FOR PENETRATING QUITE WELL.
I'M GONNA GO OUT
ON A LIMB HERE, THOUGH,
AND SAY, I THINK
MY JAMIE TILE'S GONNA STOP IT.
Narrator: BUT WILL CONFIDENCE
BE CONFIRMED BY THE CONCLUSION?
FIRING IN 3...
2...
1.
IT STOPPED IT.
IT TOTALLY STOPPED IT.
THERE YOU GO.
IT'S A 9-MILLIMETER.
I'D SAY IT'S JAMIE TILE -- 1,
BULLET -- ZERO.
Narrator: IT'S A GOOD START
FOR JAMIE'S TILE,
BUT NEXT, IT'S STARING DOWN
THE BARREL OF A .45 HANDGUN.
OH, THAT LOOKS LIKE
A NICE STOP.
BEAUTY.
HARDLY A DENT
IN THE BACK.
HA HA HA!
JAMIE TILE -- 2,
BULLETS -- ZILCH.
Narrator: NEXT UP
IN THE RAMP-UP, IT'S BUCKSHOT.
AFTER WATCHING WHAT IT DID
AGAINST THE HANDGUN ROUNDS,
I DON'T THINK BUCKSHOT'S GONNA
MAKE IT THROUGH THE JAMIE TILE.
WOW!
HA-HA-HA, HA-HA!
LOOK AT THAT.
WELL, I TELL YOU WHAT,
BUCKSHOT IS ONE OF THE SCARIEST
THINGS YOU CAN GO UP AGAINST,
AND THE JAMIE TILE STOPPED IT,
AND IT STOPPED IT COLD.
Narrator: BUT NOW
THINGS GET REALLY SERIOUS
AS BUCKSHOT TAKES A BACKSEAT,
REPLACED BY THE DEER SLUG.
THIS IS ALMOST
AN OUNCE OF LEAD.
IT'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF FORCE
COMING OUT OF THAT GUN.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE'LL BE
ABLE TO STOP IT OR NOT.
Man: RANGE IS HOT!
EYE AND EAR PROTECTION ON.
HA HA,
I SEE DEAD PEOPLE.
Narrator:
AND THE FEARS ARE FOUNDED.
WOW, LOOK AT THAT HOLE!
YOU'D BE HURTING.
YOU'D BE DEAD.
Narrator: THE DEER SLUG
WENT STRAIGHT THROUGH THE TILE
AND TOOK OUT
THE VITAL ORGANS, TOO.
OHH, IT LOOKS LIKE
THE CHAMPION'S BEEN TAKEN DOWN
BY AN UPSTART
NAMED "DEER SLUG."
Narrator:
AND AFTER THE SLOW-MOVING
BUT DEADLY DEER SHOT...
NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE .223.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE END
OF THE SCALE.
IT'S A REALLY SMALL BULLET BUT
IT'S MOVING REALLY, REALLY FAST.
Narrator: BUT CAN IT TAKE OUT
A JAMIE TILE?
RANGE IS HOT!
EYE AND EARS!
Narrator:
AND IT'S THE LAST MAN STANDING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU THINK IT WENT THROUGH?
I THINK IT WENT THROUGH.
YOU DO?
OH, LOOK AT THAT.
THERE'S THE BULLET.
THAT WOULD BE A KILL.
WOW! LOOK AT THAT.
YOU CERTAINLY
SLOWED THAT BULLET DOWN
FOR IT TO END UP IN THE GEL,
BUT HE'S DEAD.
Narrator: AND THERE'S NO ARGUING
WITH THAT.